as cars are getting smarter as they say
the dashboard once filled with dials and
gauges is being replaced by an
interactive screen and now automakers
are turning to the video game industry
for help with the design but here's
what's not getting smarter drivers and
there are concerns that this new
technology could lead to more distracted
driving Chris Van Cleave shows us now
what the future of your car may look
like
the 2023 Cadillac lyric EV comes with a
glimpse of the future what General
Motors calls its new cockpit experience
and if it feels a bit like a video game
that's because it was designed by Gamers
historically the exterior was really
what made her broke a vehicle but now
it's the combination of the exterior and
the interior it's the digital experience
is a big part of that Mike hishmey leads
GM's cockpit experience team you guys
have kind of gamified that experience
over time gaming has really influenced
the design of not just the digital
content that you see on the screens a
lot of the controls like the steering
wheel controls are inspired by video
game controllers self-described Video
Game Nerd Maddie Udi is a GM creative
designer I'm thinking about what video
games are doing that we can not only
Implement into our vehicle but also be
the the next you know Cutting Edge thing
for the vehicle she's worked on the
upcoming Cadillac celestic EV it won't
have a tradition National dashboard at
all instead it's more of a video wall
stretching across the front cabin
similar to this Mercedes EV
in fact several automakers are now using
video game technology the new Ford
Mustang screens are powered by the same
system used to develop the popular video
game fortnite oh my God it's the brain
of the car it's the only way that you
can communicate with the driver Marty
romance has runs San francisco-based
territory Studio a design firm with its
roots in video games and big budget
movies that design the user experience
for the lyric cars need the same things
that we do for movies and games which is
telling a very complex story
in a visual language which is universal
in a way that everyone can understand
what's happening there's this down
Funkhouser from Consumer Reports has
reviewed some of the new display heavy
Vehicles we're really concerned about
the drawing driver's attention away from
the road and putting it onto those
screens something the GM cockpit team
says it pays a lot of design attention
to GM uses this simulator to test
distraction to see if something they're
putting into the dashboard takes your
eyes off the road for too long video
game technology is increasingly
factoring into car design too from VR
headsets that help speed up the process
to this full motion simulator allowing
for vehicle testing on a virtual track
that looks a lot like the latest racing
game leveling up the car of the future
for CBS mornings I'm Chris Van Cleave in
Detroit
thank you
I love a pretty dashboard in a car but
you don't want it to be too fancy Dancy
because it can be very distracting yeah
it can be I like the look of it yeah but
once you learn it you're right easy you
know I took a little bit of a road trip
to celebrate my daughter's birthday in
Pennsylvania yeah a couple of hours and
I was actually driving a Cadillac and
the dashboard once you actually learn
how to use it you forget that you're
paying attention to it so it's not
distracting at all yeah not at all and
then the the rear view mirror you can
flip a switch and just turns into a
camera even my wife was in a passenger
seat she was saying are you distracted
right now no yeah didn't have any
distractions what car was it it was a
Cadillac Escalade okay plus they have
like a lane correction technology as
well so if you are drifting or
distracted for a second it'll bring you
back that's right I was in one of those
this weekend my friend Nina has a car
and you're driving it and it does a
little bumpy thing I found that very
disoriented yeah or yes I found it very
disorienting I was like turn that thing
off but it is good it is good it does
help it is a good driver that that was
disorienting but I think it's all for
your safety that's right